life is full of uncertainty in many ways
we are both the driver and the passenger
of our lives with strong self-discipline
we can make decisions that allow us to
predict and control certain things on
the surface of our life things like what
we do for work where we live
whom we associate with and how we choose
to live our daily life but even with
strong intellect reason and
self-discipline there is still a whole
realm of life that we cannot be sure
about possibilities that we can only
speculate but can never fully control
like the chance of falling out of love
or having a friend betray us the chance
of early death tragedy or health
conflicts or the chance the things we
hold to be true end up not being so all
of which is possible and all of which in
general is out of our control
this creates deep conflict because as
humans control is one of our greatest
hungers with control comes certainty and
with certainty we would no longer have
the fear of things going wrong for us or
our loved ones but life does not work
this way
more often life functions on its own
terms within the laws of its own
arbitrariness so what do we do how can
we live knowing that behind any corner
could be something that might ruin us
how can we live with this irrevocable
fear we cannot eliminate uncertainty but
we can rationalize the fear that stems
from it in life one of the only things
we have true heightened control over is
our thoughts and perspectives and we
must use what we can control to override
our fear of what we cannot if we wish to
overcome fear we must spotlight our
consciousness and rationality onto it we
can do this by constantly reminding
ourselves of this if we live in fear of
what may or may not happen we will spend
our life detached from reality suffering
from things that do not even exist we
will be our own worst enemy
self-inflicting anxiety with no purpose
and taking our self away from enjoying
the present moment which would otherwise
be precious and untainted
for example if we fear that we might
become badly ill or injured from an
unforeseen occurrence fear will not
decrease the chances of becoming ill or
injured but what it will do is create
unnecessary suffering and if we do by
some unfortunate circumstances become
ill or injured we would have wasted the
portion of our life when we were healthy
living with the mental consequences of
being unhealthy and therefore fearing
uncontrollable concepts of the future
simply does not make any rational sense
it only brings unnecessary anxiety about
that which does not exist and takes us
away from enjoying that which does
uncertainty is not something to be
afraid of it cuts both ways if it is
possible that unforeseen negative things
can happen in life then it is also
possible that unforeseen positive things
can happen to us in life and it is this
concept of randomness and
unpredictability that keeps life
exciting the only thing we can do in
life is to try our best to enjoy our
time in spite of fear so if our fears do
come true
at least we enjoy it ourselves before
the storm
thank you for watching if he found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder